so one of the big variables uh was going
to be who voted
and uh what the make up what the nature
of the electorate is going to be
and historically you had something like
seven to eight hundred thousand people
vote in these kinds of
races and the question was whether
turnout goes up
because the city is in a very tough spot
and this was
an historic election and uh turnout did
not go up to the point that
to the point that you might have hoped
uh i think right now how many votes been
kassack
seven almost eight hundred thousand just
on seven
ninety nine eight twenty seven so you
might have something like nine hundred
thousand votes
um so that's not that different from the
eight hundred thousand
in the last uh race
um so it's us it's an uptick to be sure
it's maybe a 10 uptick um
but you're still looking at the likely
winners being decided by i don't know
maybe
like 300 000 votes or so
which would be something like four
percent of the population maybe less
there are 3.2 million registered
democrats
so let's call it fewer than 30 percent
of registered democrats actually turned
out to vote
and i i will say that a number of people
expressed to me that they wanted to vote
but they weren't registered democrats
and so they could like they were
independents they couldn't
uh you had to change your registration
back in february they didn't know that
uh there was one person who said to me
he was working families party
and he thought that that meant that he
could vote in this election but he
couldn't
because you had to be a registered
democrat um so that so that that was
uh to me something that's a continuation
of the reality
of most elections really in a lot of
different environments but in new york
city where
bill de blasio got elected with 280 000
votes
back in 2013 which is you know again
maybe four percent of
of uh of the city um i think you're
going to wind up with a similar number
this time
where you have like a fairly narrow band
of voters
uh that determine the leadership
uh in the city a significant proportion
of those voters
are very very attached to
city government in some way or you know
like an institution that works with the
city in some way
and so you didn't have the massive
increase that you'd
hope for in this context and this is
something that
uh certainly we talked about a lot on
the campaign
but this speaks to to me to be to be
even bigger
where we have to make it in my opinion
easier to vote in elections like this
um for for people of um
of any uh party and certainly uh if
someone does want to vote
um we should make it easier to do so
there are other places that have same
day registration as an example where you
can like show up and
just make that registration happen so we
have what three and a half million
registered voters in new york
um of like probably what four to five
million
people are eligible to vote in the city
of any million population
you know something around there um and
you only get 800 000
or so to actually vote it's crazy how
much people don't give a [ __ ]
about either local politics or mayor
or just anything political in general
but what i learned people should care
because the mayor has a lot of say
a lot of control of how the individual
lives are people in the city
is it that they don't care they don't
know to care they don't they're
distracted by other things
the society of scarcity mindset of
scarcity you talk about where people are
too busy trying to pay rent to care
about
voting or community involvement like why
do we not give
a [ __ ] generally speaking um having the
ability to care about politics is
something of a luxury good
truly uh you know like you you you do
have
other basic needs to attend to and then
if you
uh decide to care too because i met so
many awesome candidates around the city
who were running for a city council
or comptroller other positions
um and a lot of them were going to lose
uh you know that but they were still
working their hearts out and they had
volunteers who were working their hearts
out it's really lovely and beautiful
um and you know like the the
uh ability to engage on that level i
think
is something that most people might not
have because
they're busy paying the bills they're
you know like that they're busy
um scrambling to take care of their kids
uh in particular ways uh i i
you know and i and i think it's
sometimes tough
to care um because a lot of times your
candidate doesn't win
um you know it's hard um and so there's
something that
i think ends up hardening you like you
can become more
jaded um through the process but what's
interesting is that i think most people
sense that
you know like i i have um
like an intention to help people and you
know like have big visions
um and we activated a lot of people
around those visions
nationally and then i ran for
uh office in new york city and uh
translating that vision and optimism to
people
uh was difficult uh
for a number of reasons but i think a
lot of people that had been
in politics for a while um you know i
just become accustomed to the particular
uh
way that things happen i think a lot of
people uh
ignore it because they sense that there
are these things going on
that um that they're not sure that
they'll
be able to influence and if they invest
a lot of time and energy trying to make
it happen then you know like that
they're
efforts may not be rewarded so in in a
way
people not caring is is rational which
is kind of
sad you know like that's one of the
things that i'd like to try and change
um like i want to make it rational to
care um
yeah if government doesn't work for you
why would you work to elect people in
in the government right i mean like it's
if you think you're going to get meet
the new boss same as the old boss
then why bother let me ask you this
we've talked a lot about you talked a
lot about ranked choice voting i know
you're going to write about that
in your your upcoming book um and we
talk about the need for
breaking the duopoly so there's more
parties to engage more types of people
and more people with different
ideologies you don't feel like you have
a false choice
um but that probably at least my opinion
um but i think i'm right is that it
probably won't increase the amount of
people who care
you know exponentially or enough um
one solution that's been offered and i
don't think we've ever talked about it
is mobile voting um and with like
blockchain technology and you can make
that hyper secure
theoretically um have you thought about
mobile voting or other solutions to
get more people to vote and care
yeah i i have thought about mobile
voting i have friends who are working on
it even if you enabled mobile voting
right now the folks that run these
elections are the political parties
uh and they i don't believe would
actually adopt mobile voting even though
it would theoretically dramatically
increase turnout
um which is one of the problems uh so
i'd love to enable that
i want to make it easier to vote i want
more people to be able to vote
i think that is the answer moving
forward
certainly the set of experiences has
made that even clearer to me
um and for those of you who are uh have
been
following us and the podcast for a while
first thank you
uh really grateful uh you should know
that we
are just getting started we have these
big plans for how we can help solve some
of the problems that i
ran for president on um and that's
always the big goal
is like how are we actually going to
further the vision i believe that
running for mayor
would help us further the vision i think
i was right
uh despite the outcome i think i was
right uh you know we certainly learned a
ton
made a lot of new friends
and have a firmer sense
of just what we need to do but
mobile voting is part of it zach uh
making it so that people have genuine
choices
and that the process isn't as
constrained is a part of it
um trying to get more people to care um
and make politics less of like this
insidery thing
um where you have to
subscribe to like particular behaviors
and
like commitments and whatnot in order to
have any kind of stature or say
i think uh is a part of it so the the
plan
is still um
uh the plan is still in effect you know
it's like
and one of the reasons i'm grateful to
people who are listening
is that i know over the last number of
weeks it's been
kind of a series of non-sequiturs really
but we're going to get back toward um
building up the agenda and the movement
um pretty quickly uh you know that and
the the the division is still very clear
um and i'm as excited as ever
uh yeah like that and this this
race has helped us
figure things out and learn a lot
[Music]
you